ami territorio una posizione di toys
oggi andiamo a fare l'unboxing di tuzi
calenda in giorno penso di tiger
comprati tutti svitare felicissimo
perché city maggio del cibo in alcuni di
questi ma molti di questi sono solo
giocattoli e accessori prodotti
particolari vendite molto curiosi di
aprile con voi ci saranno più di 96
software di tutto prima di tutto
mettetevi corretta e fate a dire poco
note caso mettetevi sono mai stato un
bel live che l'ora di vedere altri
boxing sorpreso calendari della mezzo e
iniziamo subito ecco che iniziamo con il
primo calendario che il meno costoso
questo calendario che stava solamente un
euro pochissimo
allora iniziamo dal primo giorno vitale
felicissimo si sa benissimo che c'è del
cibo fa numero uno ha per questo gioco
latino e come ho fatto professore latino
da fuori sommando io no io ho fatto a
forma di pecora ma ci dirà al mio lavoro
a paglino mio sentire ma non basta
quindi più polso colatino fonde
campanellina 54 per me sono 5 brescia
abbiamo nuovamente la pecorella
allora facciamo il po perché non li
possiamo mangiare tutti che non si viene
mal di pancia questo che cos'è un
alberello di natale penso da è una
paperella dove il cioccolatino con un
pupazzo di neve un angioletto
smettila iniziare a rubare tutto dare
non ci credo sei pirati un po mamma mia
perello lascia dopo tornare a memory
comunque lavorativi pensi l'alberello
stato pure giocare a memori dell 1 e noi
la palletta di neve nuovamente quindi
questo calendario dell'avvento di tiger
a un euro troverete tutti questi
cioccolati con tutti questi personaggi
che mi ritroverò anche vitale se li
mangia siamo tutti noi
allora questo calendario quassù stava a
4 euro che è comunque pochissimo ma non
c'è niente dentro
bisognava riempirlo bossi non mi dire
attacco non ci credo
lo scavo dove bisognava riempire
si prega per allora non puoi riempire
per mezzo di manuela scritto da qualche
parte non sia street band prende forza
il tipo di test quindi per 24 cielo e
sembrare ne fossero all'interno infatti
è un po fuorviante perché c'era scritto
24 piccoli regali ma dentro non c'è
niente poi fateci sapere se volete che
lo riempiamo noi magari ne faccio io uno
per di tale evitare le cose di cibo o
non per me allora il succo e all'altro e
o paure che sia la stessa cosa
come potete vedere questo scritto per 24
piccoli regali hanno specificato che m è
molto e che lo devi riempire tu e questo
mi dispiace un sacco e spero che altre
persone insomma non ci caschino è però
insomma voi e grazie a questo video ora
lo sapete
purtroppo
sì anche questo evento è veramente non
ci troviamo veramente rimasti male gli
oltre questo volevo mangiare se questo
video la giusy 10.000 la ypsilon è un po
per vitale vita l'oriente per me e poi
andiamo a fare quello che mi auguro
primo calendario a ecco perché quel
calendario che stava solamente 4 euro
che però per un calendario voto 4 euro
è un profondi questo invece non vi
preoccupate perché dentro ci sono le
cose questo costava 10 euro quindi già
un pochino più costoso quindi vediamo se
le cose dentro ne valgono di euro quindi
amo apriamo allora facciamo un regalo a
sessa quindi inizio con il numero 1 dove
lo trovi uno eccolo qua iniziamo che una
faccina di babbo natale è uno strozzino
questo è uno stampino si strappino con
la faccina di babbo natale la mostra già
qua sì ma l'immagine può premere più
forte
immagini di babbo natale questa si può
mettere tipo nelle relazioni regali fine
i regali le bigliettini dell'hangar
potuto giocare
il cioccolato non penso che ci siete
come l'ho ancora visto lo zucchino zona
ma non mi aspetto una penna con questo
non dire mazzon commerce quello del male
niente di che da sabato da aprire questo
calendario
cibo una caramella settore a forma di
caramella arancione fatali ne sai
qualcosa commentare ho preso tutto ciò
porti figli piccoli ma con una mamma è
una mini penna viola vediamo di una mini
pensavi ospite già collezionato giorno m
tra cui obama va evidenziato è uno
stampino
ok numero 55
qua ha un colore pastello e il grosso è
un bello arancione perché se tagliato a
metà forse per in modo da farlo stare la
metro è niente se per la zona che ha
fatto della regione 666 questo inserirsi
difficile 99
al contrario nel senso
se non altro pensa te devi dire un'altra
penna
forse sì fra karina brutto si mangia
mangia ma non si mangia una gomma gomma
o finora però questa è la più carina
sito che sembrava che facciamo così con
justin caramella da mangiare una gomma
questo però è verde e giustamente chi
dovevo chiaramente nel verde anche di
calendari dell'avvento che voterebbero
per niente eccolo qua un appena rese
intel
anche questa volta farò tutto ballare ma
anche questa venere pari ma no due premi
la canon questi carichi nadai ci piace
capirli da tutta intagliata fatto
pervenire bene ma contatti puoi mettere
dentro una golf e una norma smontabile
kevin e apprezzata l'idea magari per
giocare durante
ti distrae e così stai qui a smontare
imparato alla geometria fa scherzando
proseguire l'azione ma un altro pastella
bebè rosa stranamente più verde
ecco qua un altro pastello di quelli
grossi però rosa ma ci deve essere
importante il 10 euro tondo sia un babbo
natale ma porta le alte parole è il
corrotto conte formative molti mesi
seguite su instagram avrete visto lo
stress
eccolo qua ha capito non ho ancora però
una matita per tutta temperata grande
questa non c'entra nemmeno no no
urban sembra molto carino è una festa e
una palla e sono tentate le gomme oracle
molto carino che deve più carino mi so è
tutta una gomma per cancellare ma non
lavorerò per cancellare penso perché
super carino con la pallina sul cileno
neurologici caimano non ieri un altro se
provvedimento
2 comma 2 n 2 valide molto carino e
bronzo ma scusa 15 non capite delle
forbici entrando tutto e bene tutto
abbiamo delle forbici di plastica quindi
non so quanto tagliano questo per le
famose poi amici dalla punta arrotondata
per te che sei pericolosa vanno brignano
ricambiano la carta forse era insieme
[Applauso]
wow
è una gomma forma dialetto si sta
benissimo che bella gente
è molto bello molto bello si tocca il 15
e infatti ecco un'altra bomba
probabilmente è un'altra gomma a forma
di pastello viola giallo e rosa
quindi io sono a quota due gomme queste
16 tutta la tonda nastrino de corato
però fossero per aprire il nastro
adesivo chiudere i parchi lavorare mai
un altro decorativo molto dopo vediamo
cosa scambiarsi e cosa tenere numero 77
questo è bellissimo
[Musica]
sono le molle dopo pirlo ci giocavo un
po fasi disegno di un ora però non so
come funziona
mi sa che è troppo piccola questo dio ho
detto ok allora forse dopo la scambiano
con qualcosa ma chi cerca ora posso
pubblicare o ti trovi sempre i tweet
simili la serata fredda e un maialino
tutte
vediamo se riesco a tirarlo fuori da qui
come sopra la lotta con la matita
si arriva così tipo quando scrivi con la
gente ovviamente scrivere quei cancelli
temi capolinea
voglio vedere quindi una gomma majorino
che carino numero 19 19
con questa o 4 comma 2 pelle 2
temperamatite un nastro adesivo è ancora
tre gobba abbiamo un arma che questa
rappresenta più me perché mi piace
l'anno ad affrontarsi mangiare tale
veste ha fatto molto bene devo dire
molto ben rifinita tutto ok anche perché
questo lungo chissà che cosa c'è dentro
il ramo di natale righe è la rotta con
acciaccata colada né alla mamma da tale
albero di natale ricatto di natale il
topo di natale il maiale di natale
all'asinello di natale
la musica numero 21 che forma strana che
a questo spero che non sia un'altra
colomba non so perché ma fino a qualche
più perché io adoro le cose milia
massimo de vivo molto carino ignoranti
niccolo beni benissimo evidenziatore
l'altro è l'iniziatore a forma di
caramella questi sei fortunato ad aprire
l'ultimo regalo perché i ora 23 e
coprire l'ultimo che gli effetti 4
vediamo speriamo che lo sia un'altra
penna roma titta
un altro video settore campanella a
mandare sono belli eccolo qua un altro
evidenziatore caramella produrre un
ultimo entrato ecco la colla stick per
fare una slide con la colla stick da
questa è la corda speciale perché è come
si apre e si procollo non ha dubbi la
colla stick di babbo natale un mamma
natale allora questo era un potere
sempre sono gli scambi questo allora me
delle sue mi interessa
questo è l'anello maggiori fine mettiamo
che il maialino a che cosa ti interessa
dei miei
allora mi interessa il pastello
arancione davvero ok per cose toscani e
mi interessa la penna ma la verde che è
bello e ti do sì il tempo era la lite
per 7 2 per caso perché non c'è la
nostra mi piace ma la gomma questa
quindi non mi piace dell'anello
è un po così almeno cosa o la coppia di
penne lane è il castello arancione
perché si sa se la canzone la penna che
sono tutti ma non vuole dire anche la
molla senza cambi per l'evidenziatore
davvero vi piace il 2000 cambio con lo
scotch
ok la molla la bolla l'amore allora
queste erano tutte le sorprese anche una
faticosissima fine vita che sono così
così e alcune sono molto carine secondo
me le più belle quello che mi sono
iscritto sono lo scotch miniatura la
raccolta ma la palla di gomma e a te
l'areoplanino temperino il maritino
gomme tino e le 2 permette al gelo ok
alla fine 10 euro tutto questo diciamo
che non è tanto quindi adesso sapere
cosa ne pensate di questi territori
dell'aumento tiger e cosa ne questa foto
villaggio il nostro boating vi è
piaciuto a si può smontare il quale
guarda svolta tu cosa mi è piaciuto di
più tra queste sorprese fateci sapere
nei commenti
e ora vi lasciamo qua 4 caselline su cui
cliccare che ha nessuna di queste
caselline vide divertenti unboxing e
shopping
challenge assieme cliccate su quella che
preferite perché buona visione
ciao